oh hello welcome to five-second movies
on that guy with the glasses
and I'll bet many of you are wondering
exactly how this channel works well I
will tell you you see unlike other
channels five-second movies doesn't keep
its videos in the video section instead
every single video is given its own
individual channel and are then placed
in the favorites category of this
channel so if you want to watch a
five-second movie be sure to go to the
favorites section and we knock the video
section for glasses question why this is
in my own palette associate mr. puppy
the puppy what's on your mind mr. puppy
welcome every video you make a sale its
own individual channel that's a very
good question mr. puppy and I'm glad you
asked oh yes of course
you see five second movies has already
been taken off on you - not once but
twice in the past the music YouTube has
a very spelling two strikes on your out
policy of copyrighted material and once
a channel has been reported twice for
copyright infringement they
automatically take the channel off the
air and sadly media moguls like Viacom
Lion Gate and 20th Century Fox have
mistaken my work for copyright
infringement even though technically my
work is protected by Seth hire parody
clause
so no laws were actually broken instead
of consulting me about this sensitive
issue they went crying to YouTube like
pansies and had me taken off
entirely so to prevent this from
happening again I have given all my
videos their very own
and have listed all of them in my
favorite session mr. Clair's don't media
moguls hell that you're giving them free
pass and free advertising for their
moment
apparently not mr. puppy their solutions
to have people not look at the product
and not increase their sales gee they
see my granny moron sister glasses they
certainly do mr. puppy and I hope they
die but that's not the point here the
point is that five-second buoys are back
and ready for watching good point that
mr. puppy Bubba needs flame five seconds
aren't always exactly five seconds five
seconds in this case can mean 20 seconds
or 30 seconds or 10 seconds and so on so
forth however the point is not how long
they are but the fact that they are
short funny to the point and enjoyable
to watch so with that said sit back and
enjoy all my five-second movies